Ah, that's the
kind of face you make when you're left alone with a man at night.
[Music] I'm
sorry, but
sneaking out of the castle alone at night is
unbecoming of a fiancée.  I don't care if you get
hurt, I don't care. I'm not
hurt. I'm not doing anything like that. I'll
post something when you go up or down in the future. I told you that you can do whatever you want,
and I'm
selfish when I lend a hand to that.  I said you can do whatever you want,
but I did
n't say it's okay to act in a dangerous way.
[Music] You
're being too naive. I'm talking about you. I'm
definitely going to cleanse myself.
If I put a restriction on them, they'll just quietly slip out again.I think it would be better to give them
conditional permission than to dye their hair.Is it
really that
easy to understand?For me,
no, it's rather difficult to understand and
unpredictable.  I'm sure you're a certain type of person, but I'm
sure you're having fun.